speaking of lessons rand paul just
taught a very
lovely lesson to dr fauci dr fiji
only 10 more years you sheep put your
masks on only what did i say i said only
12 more years
no dr fauci you just said 10 more years
look i just it's only 15 more years of
the masks okay
that is the saiyans so dr senator
rand paul just laid out a bit of a
medical lesson for
dr fauci dr falchi we don't know whether
the pandemic started in a lab in wuhan
or evolved naturally but we should want
to know
3 million people have died from this
pandemic and that should cause us to
explore
all possibilities instead government
authorities
self-interested in continuing gain of
function research
say there's nothing to see here gain of
function
research as you know is juicing up
naturally occurring
animal viruses to infect humans to
arrive at the truth
the us government should admit that the
wuhan virology institute
was experimenting to enhance the
coronavirus's ability to infect humans
juicing up super viruses is not new
scientists in the u.s have long known
how to mutate animal viruses
to infect humans for years dr ralph
barrick a virologist in the u.s
has been collaborating with dr xi xengli
of the wuhan virology institute sharing
his discoveries about how to create
super viruses
this gain of function research has been
funded by the nih
brutal so there's the setup there the
setup which is
by the way there were a lot of people
even among conservatives who
early on in the coronavirus said this is
totally naturally occurring this has
nothing to do with the chinese
government
there's no issue here with the public
health administration it's because of
the it's the bat markets in wuhan
and on this show and on verdict with ted
cruz we said very early on
that the coincidence of
the wuhan virology institute being just
400 yards from where this
virus was allegedly discovered that's a
little too much for us i bet it has
something to do
with the institute and i bet that
some american people are going to be
held accountable for or at least going
to be exposed for this
because as we reported on that show too
u.s money u.s taxpayer dollars were
going
in part to fund the wuhan institute of
virology
which was studying coronaviruses and
bats people called conspiracy theorists
all sorts of things by the libs and by
even some self-styled conservatives
looks like we were right rand paul
laying this out in the senate
dr fauci he's he denies it but listen
this is the importance of rhetoric
listen to the way in which he denies it
dr fauci do you still support
funding of the nih funding of the lab in
wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect that the
nih has not ever and does not now fund
gain of function research in the wuhan
institute
do they follow barrick we do not
fund do you [ __ ] dr barracks gain of
function research
dr barrett does not doing gain or
function research and if it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted
in north carolina i don't think it's
oh dr fauci you know you're a you're a
clever tricky
politician but thankfully rand paul is
too and he's calling you out on it
so doctor fought you opens because dr
paul
senator paul you are completely and
totally
incorrect about this very narrow
thing that i'm actually distorting your
words on so he's not
fouchy is even though he says you're
completely and totally incorrect right
you get the sound bite
then he qualifies that he says about
this very particular thing and then you
think about the very particular thing
namely funding gain of function research
in wuhan
and you realize wait a second that's not
quite what rand paul was accusing you of
you're
you're saying you're totally wrong about
that thing that you didn't actually say
well okay so
rand paul you're totally and completely
incorrect about the thing that you
didn't actually say the u.s taxpayer
dollars do not go
toward gain of function research in
wuhan
but as rand paul asks he says well are
you funding dr barrick
this this one particular doctor doing
gain of function research which he's
then sharing with wuhan
and fauci doesn't want to answer it so
he just keeps talking over paul
and then paul axe asks it again and then
fauci gives to me
it's this is the just the cherry on top
of this little rhetorical sunday he goes
dr barrick is not conducting gain of
function research
and if he is it's fine well you go
declarative statement dr barrick is not
doing this kind of research
but if he is it's totally cool and it's
not a problem what do you mean but if
you just you're making the statement
that he's not doing it
you can't then qualify that and say yeah
but if he is whatever don't who cares
where the mask sheep
his his response to paul which is given
such fire with such passion is
ultimately
meaningless he doesn't refute a single
thing rand paul accuses him of
but people will think that he did the
way that this is being portrayed in the
mainstream media
is as the dr fauci owns rand paul that's
how it's being played
and no one's going into this depth on it
no one's analyzing what dr fauci
actually said
they're just taking it they're just
taking the dead rhetoric for what it is
but rand paul really did expose
something here doesn't matter
oh you've got to wait to see the way cnn
covers it cnn accusing
rand paul of of disrespecting medical
science rand paul
a medical doctor hey
hey you you got to ring the bell
they don't like it they don't like it
here at youtube when you ring the bell
and you get notifications
but do it do it anyway before they shut
us down ring the bell
subscribe like it we'll see you next
[Music]
time